this morning the committee is going to
consider the nomination of dr. Janet
Yellen the distinguished nominee for the
position of chairman of the Council of
Economic Advisers I've just I've
indicated to the nominee to Janet what
great affection and devotion you must
have for the President as well as this
nation to give up this magnificent
incredible position she already has a 14
year term on Federal Reserve Board had
to undertake this position and so I
believe the doctors distinguished
academic background and record and her
tenure at the Federal Reserve speak for
them selves in terms of providing then
economic views and I trust that this
nomination will be handled speedily and
anticipate expeditious action with
respect to the nomination and I know
that dr. yellen's friend and united
states senator from the great state of
California and a member of this
committee the Senate of boxers here with
the statement senator boxer so much mr.
chairman i will go through this very
quickly my colleagues and friends on the
committee who I enjoy working with so
much I am very honored to introduce you
to dr. Janet Yellen although I think
most of you know her by now the
president's nominee to serve as chairman
of the Council of Economic Advisers dr.
Yellen appeared before this committee
less than three years ago and I had the
privilege of introducing her then so we
thought we kind of keep up this
tradition because it worked out very
well the last time she's been a highly
valued and dedicated member of the
Federal Reserve as the chairman has
stated since her confirmation to that
position dr. yellen's professional
experience at academic background in
combination with her impressive list of
publications and honors make her the
perfect candidate for chairman of the
Council of Economic Advisers and i will
quickly go through her qualifications
which I think are impeccable
dr. Yellen graduated from brown
university in 1967 with a Bachelor of
Arts in economics summa [ __ ] laude with
highest honors in 71 she earned her PhD
in economics from Yale and then served
as a research fellow at MIT as an
assistant professor of economics at Yale
and as a lecturer at the London School
of Economics in 1980s she joined the
faculty of the University of California
at Berkeley one of the nation's foremost
universities and in 1992 became the
Bernard t Roca junior professor of
international business and trade at the
high school of Business at the
University of California in 1994 dr.
Yellen was confirmed as a member of the
board of governors of the Federal
Reserve with the help of many of you and
she is the wife of mr. Yellen who is
here with her oh wait say it again
George Akerlof I strike that she is the
wife of george akerlof is there with her
today and she is a mom of a teenage son
as chairman of the Council of Economic
Advisers dr. Yellen will be charged with
helping the president formulate economic
policy dr. Yellen has previously stated
she's interested in pursuing policies
which among other things raise the
standard of living for everyone and
encourage higher sustainable long-range
economic growth those are policies which
I believe both Democrats Republicans
agree or agree with and are worth
pursuing dr. yellen's wealth of academic
and professional experiences will be
invaluable asset to our country she will
help formulate guide in shape economic
policy at a critical time in our
nation's history when we're moving from
an industrial base to a 21st century
global technological base it's in it is
important that the chairman of the
Council of Economic Advisers have an
intimate knowledge of international
economics and international trade as a
scholar a nationally recognized
international economist and a
distinguished professor of international
trade dr. Yellen has all of those
qualifications for all those reasons I
hope he will agree that dr. Yellen will
be a credible and valuable addition to
the president's economic
team and I congratulate her on her
nomination I thank the chairman for his
graciousness and giving me the
opportunity to introduce to you once
again this outstanding woman thank you
very much Thank You senator senator
soybeans well thank you very much mr.
chairman I'm very pleased to join with
you in welcoming Janet Yellen back
before the Banking Committee is we
review her nomination to be chairman of
the President's Council of Economic
Advisers hsieh course is already well
known of this committee since we
reviewed and overwhelmingly supported
her nomination for her current position
as a member of the Federal Reserve Board
the president's now asked miss yellan to
leave the Federal Reserve in order to
serve as chairman of the Council of
Economic Advisers I would note that this
means giving up a full 14 year term on
the Fed for which he's been confirmed it
would not expire until the year 2008 to
serve without any fixed tenure as I
understand it Council of Economic
Advisers was established by the
Employment Act of nineteen forty six to
provide professional economic analysis
and advice to the president there have
been 16 chairs since the council was
established I was fortunate to work as
administrative assistant to one of them
Walter Heller who headed the council
under President Kennedy and I've always
had a particular appreciation in regard
for the role of the council in assisting
presidents and the formulation of
economic policy the council was created
out of a concern that the executive
branch should have the capacity for
professional economic analysis of public
policy in an article in The New York
Times Nobel laureates Jim Tobin and Bob
Solow described the role of the council
and the following terms and I quote
every president must establish his
administration's themes and goals but
translating that vision into legislation
requires
careful professional economics committed
to his goals by calling the analytical
shots as objectively as trained peace
train people possibly can the character
of that advice can significantly affect
the substance of that advice Janet
Yellen is an economist of the highest
professional standing who one who in my
view would more than meet the standards
set by professors Tobin and solo
michelin is a summa [ __ ] laude graduate
of Brown University shields a PhD in
economics from Yale served as an
assistant professor of economics at
Harvard a lecturer at LSC and prior to
her service on the Federal Reserve Board
she was a Barnard tiro a junior
professor of international business and
trade at the School of Business of the
University of California at Berkeley she
is published widely in the fields of
macroeconomics and international
economics much of her work as an
economist is focused on understanding
the causes of unemployment how they
might be alleviated as well as the
causes of price and wage rigidity by all
accounts Magellan was a respected member
of the Federal Reserve Board who carried
out her responsibilities with her
typical high professional standard on
occasion I've been critical the Fed for
being too insular an institution but I
think it's fair to say the miss yellan
service in Washington as a member of the
board has broadened her experience
enhanced her qualifications to serve as
chairman of the Council of Economic
Advisors mr. chairman I'm confident the
Michelin will provide the president
professional economic advice of the
highest order and I therefore strongly
support her nomination to be chairman of
the Council of Economic Advisors Thank
You senator sarbanes any other of the
Senators want to be heard from before we
hear from mrs. Yellen said yes Center
Faircloth
a Mac Thank You mr. chairman dr. Yellen
welcome we had the opportunity to meet
in my office a few days ago and I
thought that the discussion was was very
valuable you certainly have a wealth of
knowledge and experience in the field of
economics and I trust your tenure on the
Federal Reserve Board has increased your
sensitivity to the Fed that is
independent of political pressures and
focused on price stability dr. Yellen
has been nominated for a very
influential influential position last
year the Council of Economic Advisers
celebrated its 50th anniversary the
council has had the responsibility of
advising every president since Harry
Truman on our nation's economic policies
it is not a position to be taken lightly
since our economic policy decisions
impact the lives incomes and living
standards of every American family I'm
sure dr. Yellen would agree that it is
critical for our economic analysis and
statistics to be of the highest quality
it is essential that the president and
the Congress are provided with rigorous
and independent economic analysis and
advice too often economic facts are
distorted or ignored for political
purposes we must constantly strive to
improve our existing economic data to
keep up with our rapidly changing
economy dr. Yellen you may be taking
over the helm at the the CEA at a time
when we face many long-term economic
challenges taxes as a percentage of our
economic output is at a record high the
growth of median family income has been
anemic in recent years many large
federal programs face insolvency and our
federal debt continues to mushroom the
American people have spoken and demanded
that we balance the federal budget and
I'm sure you would agree that the
long-term in balance in our budget only
reduces our economic growth potential
simply stated we must balance the budget
so that all Americans have the
opportunity to share in the benefits of
strong growth while the economy has
shown slow and steady growth over recent
years one of my main concerns is the
complacency
that seems to exist over current growth
rates I believe our economy can and
should grow faster stronger economic
growth would mean more jobs better
paychecks and a higher standard of
living and faster growth would help us
in our efforts to balance the budget by
boosting revenues stronger economic
growth would bring new opportunities to
all Americans and a brighter future for
our children and our grandchildren as
you have probably witnessed all too
often dr. Yellen the the Federal Reserve
is often blamed for sluggish economic
growth yet simply printing more money or
artificially holding down interest rates
cannot lose long-term economic growth
genuine growth comes from hard work
creativity and improved productivity and
entrepreneurial activity therefore the
President and Congress have a tremendous
responsibility to make sure fiscal
policies foster and reward savings
investing in risk-taking the Federal
Reserve is best focused on reducing
inflation stable prices enhance economic
growth by reducing the risk of
fluctuations in interest rates currency
values and and cost inputs and the cost
of inputs for most of this century
American families have enjoyed the
benefits of stronger economic growth
with each generation leaving the next
better off but recently we have seen our
economic growth rate fall from a robust
4.4% annual average during the last five
expansions to about 2.5 percent since
1992 and still many people including
President Clinton now consider a growth
rate of 2.5% to be acceptable even
laudable we should not accept such
mediocrity and I'm sure that with the
right policy changes we can do much
better in recent years major tax hikes
increased government spending and
growing regulation have taken their toll
on the economy in the American family
conversely the periods of our nation's
strongest economic growth were marked by
lower taxes less bending and fewer
federal regulations however I'm
optimistic to see our current budget
debate focused on bipartisan support for
balancing the budget through less
spending and lower taxes I'm anxious to
hear your views on just how fast our
economy can grow maybe two point five
percent growth is all we can
expect under today's high federal tax
and deficit spending structure I'm also
interested to hear what pro-growth
policy changes you would suggest to the
president that would raise the bar for
our potential economic growth level and
with dr. Yellen strong economic skills
and experience I believe she would share
the Council of Economic Advisers with
distinction and I congratulate you on
the nomination Senator Reid mr. just
very flea where I come from anyone who
graduates at Brown University summa [ __ ]
laude is presumptively confirmable and
having met with dr. Yellen I've been
convinced beyond the presumption that
that's the case she is extraordinarily
well qualified the breadth of her
intellectual interest sources are
staggering macroeconomic theory
international economics and the recently
discussions of teen pregnancy rates and
the economic consequences of causes so I
believe she brings to this job rare
talents and a tremendous commitment to
use her position to influence policy so
that we can as Senator Mack said to grow
the economy and ensure that those
results are shared fairly throughout our
society and I'm pleased that she's here
today and then we're moving on a
confirmation Thank You mr. chairman
standard affair close Javon good morning
with y'all
nice to see you again
we met last week when you came in office
as always I was concerned about spending
money and I ask you about the fact that
three economists in the White House were
budgeted for 3.4 million dollars a year
I thought that sound is a little
expensive but you immediately assuage to
my doubts by saying that the role of the
Council of Economic Advisors was to
review government regulations and
policies and their impact upon the
private sector and possible adverse
effect of of business is that correct
the counseling center well in the last
four years I can't find a single rule or
regulation they objected to blocked or
stopped I mean I don't know how that
works out in money per year but if it
was if you stopped if the night you were
not there but I realized that was not
you about a another Berkeley protege not
one rule or regulation we can find that
it stopped now if the council of
economic advisers were to perform the
role you said it could be worth a lot of
money much more than the 3.4 but if in
four years you couldn't find one that
raises the question there are few people
in government today that are assessing
the impact of the rules and regulations
that are coming from the executive
branch in an avalanche and what they're
costing us business now if you're if the
Council of Economic Advisers really can
serve that role then it's a wonderful
wonderful service if you're Dylan's if
you do the job I think you could save
millions of dollars and questionable
rule
and regulations I hope you will take
that part of the job seriously and i
hope you will in so doing will certainly
justify your cost to the budget and if
if i may ask one personal thing the
first rule that you stop if you would
send me a copy of it i just like to know
one rule or regulation that came out the
white house that was stopped i thank you
thank you mr. senator Enzi Thank You mr.
chairman good morning members of the
committee I too want to welcome dr.
Yellen and I appreciated the opportunity
also to get to meet with you last month
to talk about the economic statuses and
the status and the challenges the
country will face I enjoyed learning
about your collaboration with your
husband on the economic studies not
every married couple has the opportunity
to work together closely like that my
wife and I had the privilege working
together in our shoe store in gillette
and I shared some of that with you most
couples though go their separate ways
eight o'clock in the morning and don't
see each other until very late that
evening because both are working for the
usually the sole purpose of providing
income for their family they are working
full time because they have to pay their
bills and their taxes not because
they're trying to pay for a second home
or luxuries with it out without an
income from both individuals the family
would suffer I believe we need a sound
family federal economic policy a policy
that encourages natural wage growth but
provides incentives for small businesses
and families and promotes long-term
economic growth a policy that gives
employees individual power over the
design of their work week we're in an
unprecedented era of economic activity
and expansion in today's international
marketplace the responsibility of those
analyzing the macroeconomic conditions
of our country and world is very great
there are many more factors that
influence the economy today than there
were ten years ago factors that have
added a new dynamic to
economy include the expansion of markets
in Asia and the former Soviet republics
the increased usage in dependence on
technology and the development of free
trade agreements even more important
than recognizing the expanding
international marketplace in my opinion
is the growing national debt we have a
five and two tenths trillion-dollar debt
that's twenty thousand dollars for every
man woman and child in this country and
the only way that we can reduce that
debt is to begin by balancing the budget
and it's been proven too many times that
the intention of balancing the budget
isn't quite good enough it's not
sufficient we keep adding programs and
that's going to bankrupt the next
generation I personally believe we need
to pass the balanced budget
constitutional amendment it's not easy
to balance the budget but we do not need
to learn how to say no to more
government I'm hoping you will be a part
of that the economic impacts of a
balanced budget will be significant we
talked about how it would lower interest
rates / economic growth and increase
investment the financial markets have
reacted favorably to suggestions of a
balanced budget the Consumer Price Index
also affects the budget in the economy
the CBO estimates that one in one tense
percentage point change in the CPI will
reduce the deficit by 148 billion and
the national debt by 691 billion by 2006
if it's not corrected entitlements will
spiral out of control eating up the
limited remains of what's called
discretionary spending we talked about
that whether we like it or not the
economic policies that we set now will
have an effect on the economy now and
into the future if confirmed as chairman
of the Council of Economic Advisers
you'll be in the unique position of
giving advice to the president and the
National Security Council this
responsibility I'm sure you're not
taking lightly and realize the impact on
your actions as chairman will affect the
performance of America's economy for the
long term the next 50 years that the
president talked about last night I look
forward to hearing your viewpoints
regarding the long-term economic
stability of the country as well as how
you believe
that we can reduce the financial stress
on America's working families assist
educational opportunities provide tax
relief and do it all under a balanced
budget Thank You mr. chairman I yield
the remainder of my time senator thanks
very much senator Hagel thank you good
morning dr. Yellen nice to have you with
us I appreciate it very much the
opportunity we had there's a little bit
about your role and background and
philosophy is you take on a very
important job for the future of our
economy I would just say first would
echo what my colleagues have presented
this morning on their concerns my
concerns your concerns the future
economic growth of this country we are
saddled with burdensome taxes strangling
regulation the real responsibility we
all have in this business is to ensure a
future for our next generation the
generation after that and you know that
I will be particularly interested in
hearing your comments this morning about
some of these very specific issues I was
rather disappointed in the president's
comments last night I thought he he
missed a great opportunity to show some
leadership on the tough issues CPI what
are we going to do about that what are
you going to advise the President to do
about the Consumer Price Index coalesce
entitlements we've got a Medicare crisis
at our doorstep those are the tough
issues that's what leadership is about
you will play a pivotal role in that and
I look forward to working with you on
that and I think you'll be an excellent
choice for this job so with that mr.
Chairman I would yield back my time now
you senator senator dodd chairman I'll
ask unanimous consent that a my prepared
remarks be included in the record and
let me just congratulate you doctor and
I I presume this has been raised by
others already and if it has then I
don't mind repeating it if it hasn't
stated I just think it's remarkable and
a time and public service that the the
the protection of the Federal Reserve
Board is a place where you could have
stayed in
and not step back into this fray and
never to have to come before committees
here and engage in the day-to-day
battles and fights that go on on how we
try and make the economy move better and
I think it deserves special recognition
I admire you immensely for doing this
you're tremendously talented and the
fact that you willing to step back in
and try and make a difference is I think
ought to be a model for others who don't
give up and and want to make a
difference so I really commend you for
that I thank you for doing it and I of
as I celso bit like my comments that and
in my comments now just to raise it with
you if you want to comment on at you may
and and obviously there's one can make a
case on all different aspects of our
economy to try and achieve growth and
and spur job creation in the country my
view is that balancing the budget is a
very important issue but but I often get
asked i was asked the other day i was at
a high school in Connecticut they said
why is this important we hear everyone
talking about it constitutional
amendments various ideas it's important
because what it does for economic growth
that's the issue the issue is economic
growth and what are the tools that we
need to have in place in order to
achieve that in balancing the budget is
a critical element obviously we've seen
the benefits of that over the last two
years with the Federal Reserve Board and
its reaction to interest rates and so
forth it has allowed money to be
borrowed at lower cost businesses expand
they hire more people so balancing the
budget is important but it's important
in the context of economic growth and
job creation an issue that I think is
critically important in the long term in
terms of economic growth and it doesn't
seem to enjoy much political cachet or
popularity is urban revitalization so
many of our problems economically
socially in the country reside in our
urban areas and certainly the chairman
of the committee here doesn't need to be
lectured about that representing the
state of New York with cities I see it
my state the most urbanized states in
America are Nevada and Utah we think of
these Coast New York and California but
the most urbanized states with obviously
Reno and
Las Vegas and salt lake city that's most
urbanized States in effect so they're
beginning to see these problems it isn't
just the east coast or Miami or as I
look around the room here a Providence
or a Hartford and and we've got to think
of some creative ways i had was
intrigued by the ideas last year using
washington DC as a model for some tax
proposals that i might be reluctant to
embrace nationally because i'm not sure
what the implications are but given the
problems of this city i think being a
bit radical and some of our ideas to try
and spur economic growth job creation
encouraging people to move back in to
these areas deserve some consideration
and I don't know if you want to comment
specifically on some of these ideas but
I would hope that we'd see more of an
effort I think while people are
reluctant to talk about urban politics
and urban revitalization I think it's an
absolutely essential ingredient if we're
going to have the kind of long-term
stability in this country and deal with
a lot of the underlying social problems
that people talk about with some
frequency so again my congratulations on
this and I thank you immensely for doing
it would you stand for the purposes of
the oath of magellan your swear affirm
that the testimony you're about to give
is the truth the whole truth nothing but
the truth so help you God I do and you
agree to appear and testify before any
duly constituted Committee of the Senate
I did thank you very much there now
pleasin delighted to hear your testimony
thank you very much chairman D'Amato
members of the committee I'm pleased to
appear before you today as President
Clinton's nominee to serve as chairman
of the Council of Economic Advisers I'm
deeply honored that the president has
nominated me to serve in this position I
would like to thank Senator boxer for
her gracious introduction and all of you
for your very supportive comments I'd
like to say how much I've appreciated
having the opportunity to meet with so
many members of this committee over the
last few weeks to discuss the challenges
facing the American economy mr. chairman
I'm grateful to you and to Senator
sarbanes
your support and for your help in moving
my nomination forward I'd also like to
introduce my husband George Akerlof a
professor of economics at Berkeley and
senior fellow at the Brookings
Institution who is my partner not only
in marriage but also in economic
research and I'd also like to introduce
my brother John Yellen and my
sister-in-law Allison Brooks who were
here today as well the Council of
Economic Advisers established by the
Employment Act of nineteen forty six has
served for fifty years as a trustworthy
and persistent advocate of policies that
promote the broad public interest
president since Harry Truman have turned
to the council for economic advice
analysis and insights to inform the
policy-making process in Republican and
Democratic administrations alike the
council has urged policies that
facilitate the workings of the market
that emphasize the importance of
incentives and efficiency and the
promote long-term growth if confirmed I
pledge to continue this proud tradition
by many measures the economy is in very
good health a simple index of economic
performance that reveals how well the
economy is functioning is the misery
index defined as the sum of the
inflation in unemployment rates this
index stood at 8.3 percent in 1996 with
unemployment rate averaging five point
four percent and the CPI rising
year-over-year at two-point-nine percent
in historical terms this represents
outstanding performance the best since
nineteen sixty eight over 11 million new
jobs have been created since 1992 and
the jobs have been disproportionately
good jobs in industry occupations paying
above median wages the rewards from
growth have been widely shared
with the poverty rate falling more in
1995 than at any time during the last
decade throughout our long expansion
inflation has remained low and it's
fallen by most broad measures an
investment in plant and equipment which
has been the driving force of this
expansion has grown at a phenomenal pace
consumer confidence now stands near the
highs of recent decades the
administration's economic policies have
contributed to these successes in part
by bringing the federal budget deficit
down thus permitting a larger share of
private sector savings to finance the
investments in plant and equipment that
equip American workers with the tools
they need to be productive on the job I
believe the Federal Reserve has also
played a positive and complementary role
by pursuing monetary policies that have
facilitated this favorable mix shift
while keeping the economy operating at
its potential in spite of the favorable
combination of low unemployment and low
inflation that we now enjoy numerous
economic challenges remain a major task
many of you mentioned this is to raise
the rate of productivity of growth above
the pace that we have experienced since
the mid-1970s to accomplish this our
economy needs to invest more in capital
in people and in technology and we need
competitive and open markets so that
America's scarce resources flow into
their most productive uses these are the
four ways of promoting more rapid
productivity growth the attainment of a
balanced budget agreement which is a
shared top priority of the
administration and of Congress will
facilitate faster investment in capital
the payoff from this investment will
accrue for many decades to come
investing in people through education
and training will also help the economy
grow by ensuring that American workers
have the skills they need to be
effective in the workplace and to adapt
to the shifting demands of the labor
market education is the key to
guaranteeing all Americans the
opportunity to realize their personal
potential and ensuring that the benefits
of more rapid growth are distributed
widely among American households we need
to reverse the disturbing trend that
emerged in the 1970s toward widening of
the gap in earnings between those at the
upper end of the wage distribution and
those at the bottom a particular
challenge will be to alleviate poverty
and to ensure that the transition of
low-skilled individuals from welfare to
work is successful and we must also
anticipate the economic demands that an
aging population will place on the
American economy mr. chairman less than
three years ago President Clinton
nominated me to serve as a member of the
board of governors of the Federal
Reserve System and this committee voted
to recommend my confirmation I greatly
appreciate the confidence that you
thereby expressed in my ability to help
craft a monetary policy geared toward
sustainable non-inflationary growth and
supervisory and regulatory policies
oriented toward the safe and sound
operation of our financial system it has
been a privilege in honor and also in
education to work with chairman
Greenspan with vice chairs rivlin and
blinder with a dedicated knowledgeable
and collegial group of governors and the
feds highly able and professional stay
f in the pursuit of these goals I do
greatly regret leaving the Federal
Reserve but I feel far better prepared
to contribute to the work of the Council
of Economic Advisers as a consequence of
this prior experience your presentation
I just want to make one observation and
I think it's important senator Faircloth
has touched on it raised a question as
it relates to what the council has done
previously as it relates to looking at
some of the rules and the regulations to
come and i think that's that's very
important more importantly probably one
of the things that we have not done
because of the press of business and
oversight is had the involvement of the
council both formally and informally to
get a sharing with you those ideas and
those things that you're working with we
sent a day to day basis and I would hope
that we would have that opportunity you
have an extraordinary opportunity to do
more than just let's say be the
spokesperson for the administration as
such per se and we expect you to work in
a nun take and put forth the
administration's view but to share with
us the kinds of things that we're
looking at and why and I would hope that
in our oversight we'd have that
opportunity to invite you back more than
just the customary annual review I would
look forward to die I think it could be
productive for all of us have a chance
to participate with you in that way
thank you thank you very much senator
sarbanes I want to thank a doctor
yelling for a very fine statement and I
really i'm anxious to get her on the job
so i really don't
any questions and I just passed at this
point senator Mack well I'm anxious to
get her on the job as well but I can't
pass that the opportunity to just ask a
couple questions that I believe her are
not anything other than really the
pursuit of knowledge with respect to
economics and as I listened to you talk
about leaving the Fed and the experience
that you've had there at senator Dodds
comments with respect to your background
and in many ways I'm envious of the
opportunity that you've had economics
has always been a very interesting
subject for me and so I appreciate the
opportunity to have some discussion with
you I think the place i would start was
is just to ask you from your perspective
should we be satisfied with two and a
half percent growth senator i am not
satisfied with two and a half percent
growth and i don't think any of us
should be satisfied with two and a half
percent growth and i agree with many of
the things that you said in your opening
statement on this subject i think we
ought to be focusing on and trying to
pursue policies that raise that growth
rate and for exactly the reasons that
you mentioned that nothing is more
important than rapid productivity growth
to the standards of living standard of
living of americans now and in the
future so i consider it a very important
priority as you mentioned the federal
reserve i think does what it can and
i've tried to work with the federal
reserve to achieve this to focus on
attaining price stability and to keep
the economy operating near its potential
so that we don't have slacked resources
and so that the scarce resources we have
are fully utilized and beyond that there
are lots of things that can be done I
think to spur growth and as I mentioned
in my opening statement they fall in
four categories right now balancing the
budget which is the president's
priority and I know the top priority of
Congress that is certainly something we
can do should do need to do to spur
productivity growth and it will result
in more of our economies savings going
into investment we've made an awful lot
of progress budget deficits have come
way down we're now at a point where we
have a lower budget deficit relative to
our GDP than any major industrialized
country in the world we have some more
to go and I hope we can complete the job
and of course last night the president
emphasized education which is also very
important I would add to the list
policies that create a favorable
environment for research and development
and technological change and then a
broad range of policies to make sure we
have competitive markets which keep
firms and businesses on their toes
trying to compete to innovate win
markets to win customers open markets
that we should make sure that we pursue
policies to keep our markets open and
try to open markets for our firms in the
rest of the world again I agree with
them with much if not all of what you
said but there's one area that you that
you did not mention and that is and let
me ask it in a very broad way you didn't
mention tax policy do you believe tax
policy affects growth rates I senator I
believe that there are always impacts
but a question is how large the impacts
are of taxes on decisions and in that
sense I think certainly the tax
structure to some extent impacts
decisions about work and investment
other things equal lower taxes are
better than higher taxes and the
president has emphasized the importance
of trying to achieve
some cuts in taxes I don't think we're
at a point where there's any need to
contemplate raising taxes certainly at
this point to balance the budget beyond
that general point of different kinds of
taxes I think have different impacts on
savings investment and work in the
economy and they're important
quantitative questions they're about the
impact of different forms of taxes is
that an area that I mean as you know
there's been quite a debate around the
Congress for a number of years with
respect to tax policy marginal tax rates
capital gains tax rates I just I'm I
guess maybe I'm a little disappointed
that there's not more of an emphasis in
what you had to say about tax policy
maybe that's a a perspective that which
I that I have a different perspective
than you do and feel that tax policy and
it does have a great impact on economic
growth and maybe we'll have an
opportunity over these next several
years to talk more about that but I hope
we will ensure we welcome senator Dodd
Joe and I raised the just the issue of
the urban revitalization issue and and
if you have a comment you'd like to make
on it I'd be interested in hearing it
but again I congratulate you on this
nomination look forward to working with
you Thank You senator I I share your
view that urban revitalization is
important I think many of our children
are growing up in environments that are
not safe and not conducive to their long
run best development and these are
complicated problems I don't know quite
what the magic bullet is to solve that
but I certainly think that they should
be a priority I understand that the
President may address this I to some
extent in his in his budget I've not
participated in that but he may propose
some policies that would be would be
helpful certainly during my time at the
federal
survived had a chance to see some of the
exciting things that are going on in
terms of redevelopment of urban
neighborhoods with serious blight and I
have the sense that Enterprise Zones are
having a favorable having a favorable
effect in stimulating development in
some extremely depressed areas of our
country common favorably or unfavorably
on it but to maybe bring it back to the
council there are several of us here
that are looking at ways in which we
might get some more resources into the
infrastructure needs of our states and
cities obviously we have budget
constraints for trying to balance the
budget in the and the the dollars
available to the appropriations process
are very limited particularly given the
need that exists I think in the city of
New York alone you could swallow up the
entire federal budget when it comes to
infrastructure and still have needs that
need to be met one idea that's being
floated around and it's is really an
idea at this point the three or four
years ago we had that for sent gasoline
tax that went on and obviously a source
of some contention here but it none of
the funds go into the transportation
accounts went to deficit reduction that
four cents that four cents a little more
than four cents as you know amounts to
about somewhere between four and five
billion dollars a year that comes into
the end to the Treasury and over five
years or so obviously 20 25 billion
dollars there's been some talk of
establishing a trust where you'd
leverage that 25 billion and to around
100 to 150 billion for infrastructure
needs and defined infrastructure and
broad enough terms so it's not limited
to transportation states may find that
they have other needs other than
transportation needs and allow them to
determine what those needs are within a
definable area of infrastructure because
I like tax policy other things I don't
believe you're going to have economic
growth unless you've got a sound strong
infrastructure at least we've never had
it in our country and if you don't make
those intelligent investments it's not
going to happen we don't have the
resources in our budget to do it so
we've got to be creative and look for
ways in which we might
bring some of these resources to bear
and as I say there a number of us around
here been talking about this we're going
to have a discussion next week with some
people who have thought about this in a
bit more detail and I wonder if you
might just be willing to carry that back
and examine that as an idea that you
might find some strong bipartisan
support up here for something like that
and urge you to take a look at it could
I appreciate that i'll make sure that we
do it's an interesting suggestion
hearing senator Faircloth Thank You
senator but by the way if I might we've
never really gotten even from mass
transit to full penny it was supposed to
be allotted as related to distribution
for mass transit of that one out of five
cents and it just seems to me and I
share with my colleagues who may not
quite have in there the totality of
their states at the magnitude is that
some of us have some some of the
Senators you have some of the problems
we talk about infrastructure were
talking about sewage treatment plants
federal government does not provide the
kind of a t20 or 9010 match that at one
point in time they did some years ago
you cannot we talk about the environment
and and about wanting it better in a
cleaner environment as well if your
harbors in your rivers are being
polluted and these cities do not have
the financial wherewithal to undertake
these becomes important and so looking
at the possibilities of having and
sharing part of that revenue over a
period of time might be something that
we can and should look at and giving to
the states and local communities the
opportunity broadly to utilize these
within those those functions as it
relates to infrastructure so it not be
simply roads and highways I think it's
something that we should examine so I
want to join with the senator and in
pointing pointing a senator Faircloth
like Thank You mr. chairman and I agree
with the direction you were talking in
ah ms yellen I noticed you agreed and
said that a balanced budget would spur
the economy protect the future of the
country and that seems to be pretty much
a universal opinion that we have arrived
at as a nation would you believe in a
constitutional amendment to assure that
that happens every year senator I'm
strongly opposed to a constitutional
amendment to balance the budget I think
it is as I emphasized very important to
balance the budget and I believe we're
making progress I believe that the
administration and Congress are both
committed to making this happen and I
simply do not think that it is necessary
to have a constitutional amendment to
balance the budget it will not help at
all in making the hard decisions that
are necessary to actually achieve the
savings to make the books balanced and
I'm very concerned that a balanced
budget amendment will have a number of
adverse effects that I'm greatly
concerned about as you undoubtedly know
over a thousand economists including 11
Nobel Prize winners have emphasized that
they think this is a bad idea and
chairman Greenspan has also emphasized
that he thinks a balanced budget
amendment is not the way to proceed on
this those are sentiments I certainly
share but I ask your question
we all agree that a balanced budget is
good idea but we feel it ought to be
left up to the Congress each year to
decide whether we do it or not we don't
want to fix it into law you know it
might not be the world's best analogy
but it might not be the worst one the
First Amendment is a wonderful idea
hidden it yes all right glad you agree
but the Congress could every year pass a
first amendment bill without having it
as a constitutional amendment cut it
suppose that's possible if possible you
could cut it every year the Congress the
president could come up with a law we're
going to have a freedom of speech in
this country and we're gonna pass a law
this year say in UK the balanced budget
assures the fiscal responsibility of
this country on into the future I think
it is something that as it would be
ludicrous disease in this country to
think that we had to debate and go
through filibusters and all of those
things to assure that we had freedom of
speech every year what I blew that
freedom of speech is the kind of
fundamental right that the founding
fathers sought to guarantee i try to
attack and defend us and then there's
nothing more fundamental in this country
than the fiscal integrity of this nation
and we severely need a balanced budget
amendment to bring it about but let me
ask you another question mr. Yelland as
a chairman in the bush administration
michael bowl skin has recommended
Council of Economic Advisers chairman
during the Bush administration has
recommended that we change the Consumer
Price Index formula which would mean a
cut in today's formula and reduce the
colas for retirees do you agree or
disagree with his commission's report uh
senator I agree with the principle that
Social Security in cat the tax system
should be appropriately indexed to take
account of movements in the cost of
living and I believe we need as accurate
a measure as we can possibly have of the
cost of living and the issue of what is
the appropriate measure is one I think
on which this should not be politicised
it's something we're professionals need
to sit down and see if they can find
agreement I believe that we're now
obtaining broad agreement among
professionals that the CPI does
overstate the
the actual increase properly measured in
the cost of living a little bit one
quick question before you raise that
question senator Moseley Braun has
another committee hearing and she'd like
to put a statement in the record so
could I acknowledge her just for that
purpose thank you thank you so much mr.
chairman and thank you very much senator
Faircloth miss yellan I did want to put
my statement in the record and had
wanted to explore with you the the part
of the statement which had to do with
the fact that other industrialized
nations are going through the same kind
of fiscal challenges that we are and
adjusting our of response is the
critical is the critical issue that in
the Congress we're trying to take up
right now I was delighted that your
comment about education and would call
to your attention and picking up frankly
with mr. Dodd left off call to your
attention the president's mentioning
last night in the state of the union
address the initiative on education
infrastructure certainly education as
the president pointed out really is a
matter of national security in this
global economy in this information age
and if we can find creative ways to help
provide and beef up the federal support
of elementary and secondary education so
as to provide an opportunity for our
young people to to get access to
computers in the light yes then I think
that's all together appropriate and
while I can't I would like to have asked
you a question about it but I have a
commitment i'm already a few minutes
late for and i just want to thank the
chairman for his indulgence and call
that to your attention because education
infrastructure is a very i think not
only appropriate but it is an
opportunity for us to do something at
this level thank you very much Thank You
senator senator Faircloth guess I'm
going to have to go preside at the
Senate I'd ask for permission to submit
some questions and right let me say
senator so ordered of any senators who
wish to submit questions will keep the
record open for the balance of of the
week so that they might do that and we
would ask you magellan if you I might
not respond to them and write
I would be happy to respond to nightly
be deeply appreciative an a cause for
those who are here and those senators
indicate to their staff now don't feel
compelled to just make up questioning
now staffers you know well we'll keep it
by the end yeah we'll keep by the end by
the end of tomorrow so that if there are
any questions that in senators are those
representatives on behalf of their
Senators I shouldn't probably open it up
because you'll get deludes with
questions your staff lobster I praise
questions but seriously if you have any
and in any questions let's keep the
record open till tomorrow to do that our
senator Enzi senator air quality I know
you wanted to finish up on that question
yeah well two quick questions and I
would just love a yes or no answer
should we reduce capital gains tax put
any capital gains tax it up should we I
can't give you a yes or no on that I
think it depends on the details if it's
how it's done and whether or not it's
consistent with the broad objectives
that I agree with it the president is
outlined on in this area that it be
targeted at middle-income families but
you would not a broad-based be
supportive of a capital gains tax across
the board I would not regard it as a
high priority at this time as a former
member of the Federal Reserve Board do
you think we should modernize the
banking system and if so should we go so
far as to allowing banks and commerce to
mix I do believe it's important to
modernize the financial system at this
time and on the issue of Commerce and
banking I would begin by saying that I'm
not philosophically opposed to mixing
banking in commerce on the other hand it
seems to me that we have a lot more
experience and knowledge about financial
activities that most of the synergies
that I think exists between banking and
other lines that are in the financial
area and i would think that that's an
appropriate first step okay my
temptation would be to go slow until we
have some more experience with banking
and commerce thank you to read Thank You
mr. German docum I also would like you
swiftly and exposition to confirm so I
have two quick questions I hope one
underlying a lot of the debt are
nationally about the economy good and
bad has been some regional divergences
right now we're enjoying nationally
robust growth but there are some reasons
that still sort of stuck and many times
it's the Northeast and I wonder what
thoughts or comments you have about it
perhaps it's an elaboration centaur
Dodds comments about targeting programs
through areas of the country they're
distressed but in terms of regional
recessions regional problems how would
you propose to do I think that's an
important and difficult question senator
I think to some extent our tax system
automatically in transfer system
automatically cushions for regions that
suffer shocks cushions the tax impact
and generate some additional support
through transfers beyond that I don't
have a simple answer as to what we can
do these are extremely difficult
problems and I would be happy to give it
some more give it some more thought just
a follow-up question that if a
constitutional amendment to balance
budget would be adopted those automatic
provisions which cushion regional
recessions would essentially not perhaps
an operative yes I think if we had a
recession it was localized not national
in it's not uniformly national in scope
and we've certainly seen many examples
of that the pressure to balance the
budget year in and year out could make
it very difficult to support read
regions that had particular difficulties
I mean
another question slightly different
question is that the with the Wall
Street booming and the stock market
running up at fantastic kites can you
just comment generally on the adequacy
of capital formation today in the United
States well with respect to capital
formation we have seen an enormous pick
up in capital formation in this country
we have seen phenomenal pace growth of
investment in plant and equipment and
more recently resident non residential
structures in this country and I take
that as a very good sign for the future
that capital formation is picking up
we've had the fastest pace i believe of
increase in industrial capacity over the
last few years that we've seen in
decades and this pace has not been
prompted by any specific tax policy to
use a favor capital formation or
essentially it's been happening for
factors if I was an economist I said
what X Janice to the executives yes yes
I think because partly because the
deficit has come down so much and
deficits are not the only thing that
affect interest rates in our economy but
they are one thing that affects interest
rates and I believe that getting those
deficits down has led to more favorable
financial conditions for investment and
we've had a strong economy and the kinds
of conditions where I think firms feel
confident about the future confident
about the management of our economy and
the likely success they will have if
they if they take a chance and invest in
this economy and I think that's mainly
would so spurred it thank you very much
dr. Yellen mr. Thank You senator senator
Allen Thank You mr. chairman I'd like to
have permission to insert my opening
comments on the record I want your chair
I appreciate you taking the time to come
by my office and visit with me time went
too fast while you were there
appreciated to them when when we talk
about our deficits can you ever foresee
a scenario where you may advise the
president that we shouldn't worry about
the deficits I can't imagine
circumstances where I would not regard
it as appropriate in the short term to
take an action to alleviate a deficit in
a short period of time can you share
with us a couple of examples where you
might give that recommendation well if
we had achieved the balanced budget and
sometimes economists distinguish between
structural budgets and cyclical cyclical
budgets or deaf budget deficits if our
budget were in balance and the economy
were operating at full employment and
then we had a very severe shock that
through our economy into recession to
turn around and immediately and quickly
attempt to cut government spending in
order to within a year bring the budget
back into balance in my view would be
counterproductive would make the
recession worse and would be extremely
costly there would be a situation where
the structural budget would remain in
balance but we would have a temporary
cyclical deficit one can imagine life is
very long and one can imagine
circumstances wars I know is something
that's been considering the balanced
budget amendment but there are natural
tragedies and circumstances that are
hard to spell out in advance where we
might regard it is desirable for some
period of time to have the deficit in
the budget and so can I imagine
circumstances yes I can sounds to me on
the one first example it your might be
described as a Keynesian
in other words you think there is a role
of government and stimulating the
economy well I'm not talking here about
any active role of government I'm
talking about the natural mechanisms
that are built into our fiscal policy as
it stands not anything that requires
action of Congress or the president but
simply the natural feature of the tax
system that when a shock occurs that
might propagate and become more severe
as it works its way through the economy
individuals when their income fall they
find that their tax the need to pay
taxes is reduced and that cushions the
shock on their income and it mitigates
the impact on their spending and that's
something that is at work day-in day-out
in our economy that makes recessions
less severe than they otherwise would
I'm not talking here about any conscious
fiscal policy this is simply what's
called the built-in automatic
stabilizers and I think that short
circuiting those stabilizers would be a
very foolish thing to do now more on the
long-term let's talk about the debt yeah
you think the debt today has an adverse
impact on our economy of five point
three trillion dollars well we've
succeeded at this point in stabilizing
the ratio of debt to GDP at about fifty
percent but it does have an adverse
effect in the sense that a significant
share of the tax revenue that's
collected now has to be used to pay
interest on that debt and that means at
this point that tax rates are higher
than they would otherwise need to be or
we can spend less on other programs that
we regard as desirable because of that
in view of the large debt that we're
carrying right now you admit that it
does have an adverse impact on the
economy
does it in view of that does it make it
more difficult for you to recommend to
the president that we should not deficit
spend I know it doesn't make it more
difficult i as i indicated i believe
right now that a balanced budget is
certainly a desirable and extremely
desirable goal and there's no question
about that earlier you asked me could I
ever envision circumstances and i would
say never say never right now there's
not the slightest question in my own
mind that we ought to be we ought to be
quickly working toward a balanced budget
and you and I and other members of this
can they differ as to whether that we
need to have a balanced budget amendment
or not Mike my concern is that we have
individuals in the Congress great
individuals and intention well
intentioned individuals but when we have
the body politics of work you end up
spending more money than what you have
coming in so in light of recent history
or the Congress seems to battle these
political pressures and it doesn't
balance the budget you still would
oppose a balanced budget amendment I
would still oppose balanced budget
amendment I understand the frustration
that you must feel about the situation
that's prevailed not being able to get
agreement I think it's very important to
get agreement and to balance the budget
now but i would still strongly oppose a
balanced budget amendment this is
writing something into the constitution
for all time and i think that that would
be a serious error Thank You mr.
chairman Thank You senator senator Hagel
dr. Yellen I guess we're not going to
get you on record supporting a balanced
budget amendment even get me to agree in
private sector I would like to pick up
on that because as the president
expressed last night and my colleagues
this morning I've talked about it
everybody's talking about a balanced
budget and I've yet to hear anybody who
is opposed to it maybe there is someone
but I have not yet known of that person
in this body and you mentioned that the
hard decisions are going to have to be
made that's right a balanced budget
amendment will not make the hard
decisions we understand it but when you
look at the history of this body 36 out
of the last 37 budgets have not been
balanced our former colleague Paul Simon
had a very interesting new york times
editorial last week and one of the
things that Senator Simon observed was
that politicians like to do good things
for people they like to do popular
things and popular things usually
require money so we talked about
programs that we're going to do for
everybody and somehow at least 36 out of
last 37 budgets the good things about
numbered the resources and we haven't
balanced that very well and what I'd
like to ask you in light of this
conversation and debate which will start
as you know today about a balanced
budget amendment and we'll debate that
out on the floor of the Congress as it
should be and should and should engage
all of America in this debate because it
is important it is about our future and
you understand that better than most
where do the hard decisions come from
how are you going to advise the
president united states to balance the
budget where where do we balance the
budget your opinion do we cut
entitlement programs do we cut defense
how do we get there one other thing you
mentioned about deficits going down
that's true but you've seen the CBO
numbers that have just come out recently
where they project deficits going back
up so in light of that dr. Yellen how do
you get your arms around advising the
President and I know there are others
who will advise him how do you make
those hard choices and where do you make
the tough decisions to balance this
budget if you don't
have a balanced budget amendment
constitutionally mandating some
discipline on a very undisciplined body
well without any amendment at all
senator the budget deficit has come down
in part is a con as a consequence of the
legislation that was passed in nineteen
ninety-three third long backers did
impose some difficult decisions and my
understanding I've not been involved in
the budget process i'll be looking
forward to seeing what's in the budget
as i know all of us will the president
is going to propose a budget that
balances that is balanced by 2002 and
I've not participated in the discussion
about what the trade-offs are clearly
this involves difficult tough trade-offs
I haven't been involved in this round of
making them and I can't comment
explicitly on what would I do if got
given dr. Yellen would you share the
committee just some general thoughts are
we going to have to get these savings
out of entitlements well sir I think
that in the long run as we look forward
to the retirement of the baby boomers
and to an aging population we are likely
if things remain as they are to see
rising budget deficits under unchanged
policies and this is a long time in the
future it's not a problem now but it
certainly would be a good thing to begin
to address this early and personally I
would support attempting to begin to
wrangle with the tough issues that will
come out there for us in the future as
early as we possibly can i look forward
to working with the president of
congress on that thank you well senator
i want to tell you i'm very pleased that
you asked that question and dr. Yellen
you are about as forthcoming as anybody
could possibly hope dealing with that
potentially explosive nature of how your
candid answer could be interpreted by
various groups and now you could find
yourself being assailed and I think it's
crushing and I think it's implies i
think senator Hagel recognize that I
don't mean to be and I want to
compliment the senator and I want to
thank you for your candor it is
refreshing I am tremendously pleased
that you will be taking on this
important assignment I think you make a
great contribution in terms of your own
person and undertaking this and I will
work with the ranking member who has
been I just want to tell you you're one
of your greatest boosters and the reason
that we've held this hearing today and
no small part comes through the strong
recommendation of the ranking member to
move the process and we will look
forward with the leadership of bringing
hopefully your your nomination to the
floor early during this coming week
certainly that will be our
recommendation and I anticipate having a
a markup and a vote and I anticipate a
unanimous vote out of this committee
thank you and we are extremely pleased
to have you here today and I want to
thank you thank you I'm very grateful
mr. Chairman I just want to take one
moment just to show this chart and make
the point on this on the automatic
stabilizers which dr. Yellen spoke about
and I think as we debate the balanced
budget amendment this chart will become
more and more relevant we really only
accept it as public policy automatic
stabilizers since World War two the end
of World War two and as dr. Yellen
pointed out when we go into an economic
downturn we don't then try to raise
taxes or cut spending in order to stay
at violence because we recognize that
that would only drive the economy even
further down we try to cushion the
downturn and bring the economy back and
that serves an ameliorating effect and
this chart is a rather dramatic
demonstration of the consequences of
that policy thee as you can see we still
get the business cycle but we've managed
to preclude the very deep
troughs that we used to experience an
economic fluctuation in this country and
of course the Great Depression was the
classic example of that and these fiscal
stabilizers the automatic ones plus an
addition conscious fiscal policy on
occasions by the Congress and the
president joining together have in
effect ease the business cycle now we
still get down turns but at least we
don't get those and I think a balanced
budget amendment to the Constitution
which in effect would I think preclude
the use of the automatic stabilizers is
going to take us back to the old days
it's going to turn an economic downturn
into a recession is going to turn a
recession into a depression and I think
this chart is a pretty dramatic
illustration of that of that point but I
don't I don't really want to press it
any further senator thank you dr. Yellen
and want to thank you I thank Laura
colleagues we look forward to your sbd
reporting out from this committee to the
floor of the Senate and I think the
leadership will and a bipartisan method
be voting on you this coming week again
thank you for incubation piano research
thank you
wrong